ciao marinese benvenuti un nuovissimo
video è già da qualche giorno che in un
pubblico video e ci tenevamo insomma
parlare un po con voi
ovviamente questa emergenza che stiamo
vivendo è uno dei motivi per cui insomma
sto pubblicando un po un po meno è
ufficiale la situazione è grave nostro
paese deve affrontare questo enorme
problema chiamata coronavirus e niente
volevo parlare un po con voi di come sto
vivendo io questa situazione e vi
leggerò alcuni messaggi che ho ricevuto
in questi giorni di alcuni di voi che mi
hanno raccontato insomma come la stanno
vivendo
inizierei dunque a insomma raccontarvi
come la sto vivendo io e che cosa ha
fatto in questi giorni diciamo di
assenza dal canale per chi non lo
sapesse io vivo a milano e appunto
durante la fashion week che è stata dal
18 al 24 febbraio ci sono tutte le varie
sfilate dei vari brand e alcuni di
questi preti hanno invitato alle loro
sfilate quindi contentissima
insomma chi mi segue su instagram stock
avrà visto sono date nel backstage e le
sfilate ho indossato i vestiti appunto
dei brand è stata un'esperienza molto
molto bella e purtroppo l'ultimo giorno
gli avevo l'ultima sfilata sono state
annullate tutte le sfilate perché
appunto per prevenire il contagio i
contagi e e se vi devo dire la verità
all'inizio non ero molto preoccupata io
sono una persona abbastanza ansiosa e
infatti mi sono stupita di me stessa
proprio detto cavolo sono tranquilla la
colpa sarà punta dei giorni i contagiati
sono aumentati i media non hanno fatto
altro appunto che che parlare
giustamente del del problema
ho notato però che sia alimentata anche
molto la psicosi
finita la fashion week sono stata
appunto alcuni giorni a casa a riposare
e però appunto più aumentava questa
a questa ansia da coronavirus più ho
evitato insomma di uscire di casa
io perché non sapesse convivo con il mio
il mio ragazzo ormai da otto anni e
quindi siamo stati a casa io e lui
tranquilli
ieri sera si è scatenato il panico
perché all'incirca alle dieci di sera
hanno diffuso una bozza di decreto in
fase devo ancora in fase di approvazione
secondo la quale la lombardia e altre 14
province nel giro di poche ore sarebbero
state chiuse
in che senso nel senso che nessuno può
più entrarvi o uscire
sono sincera per la prima volta in
questi somma in questo mese ormai di
emergenza vi è venuta l'ansia mi è
venuta l'ansia non più che altro per il
virus insieme a colpo per la sensazione
di rimanere chiusi in insomma in un
nella propria nella propria regione e
non poter vedere la propria famiglia per
un mese
però poi abbiamo ragionato e abbiamo
detto se tutti scappassero da milano per
raggiungere le proprie famiglie per
trascorrere questo mese diciamo di
blocco totale con i propri cari non
farebbero altro che spargere questo
eventuale di virus che non sappiamo se
ce l'abbiamo già abbiamo
potrebbe essere ovunque e diffonderlo e
contagiare le persone insomma i propri
cari o comunque gli abitanti di altre
zone del nostro paese
io non avevo mai parlato sui social fino
ad ora appunto del problema coronavirus
ieri sera mi sono sentita li chiederà
chi mi segue su instagram come se sto
vivendo questa situazione per insomma
non lo so per cercare di stare un po più
vicini di di sostenerci a vicenda perché
abbiamo bisogno prima di leggere alcuni
messaggi che ho ricevuto appunto
sera volevo condividere con voi il il
poco buon secondo me che hanno avuto
tutti coloro che ieri notte hanno preso
l'ultimo treno in partenza appunto da
milano per raggiungere le proprie
famiglie
il proprio paese o città e l'ho trovato
veramente scorretto perché è il
desiderio di tutti poter stare in un
momento del genere con i propri cari ma
bisogna anche usare la testa e se
bloccano arrivano se arrivano bloccare
appunto dei paesi delle regioni
significa che stiamo cercando i più
positivi di contenere questo virus e se
ce ne andiamo e scappiamo lo portiamo in
giro per tutta italia non facciamo altro
che peggiorare la situazione
la mia domanda era appunto come state
vivendo questa situazione critica e
giada risponde con estrema ansia non ce
la faccio più a sentire cose negative mi
sembra che la fine del mondo si avvicina
e io sono ancora così piccola all'inizio
di questo 2020 sta per scoppiare terza
guerra mondiale poi la strada che brucia
quei primi 29 contagiati in cina no
tranquilla non arriverà mai in italia 6
contagiati in lombardia e così via
voglio solo che tutto questo finisca il
prima possibile per poter tornare a
vivere una vita normale con meno ansia
sono negli stati uniti da otto mesi la
mia famiglia in italia in zona rossa
preoccupate dire poco vorrei essere a
casa con loro sono abbastanza giù di
morale perché dopo mesi di lavoro e
qualche attacco di panico per scrivere
la tesi magistrale finalmente sono
prossima alla laurea
quasi sicuramente con discussione su
skype o a porte chiuse
in più il mio ragazzo vive a parigi è la
mia migliore amica in erasmus
quindi se anche voi essere realizzare
una piccola festa intima per festeggiare
mancherebbero due tra le persone più
importanti per me me la immaginavo
diversa la fine di questo percorso ma
penso alle persone che stanno male che
hanno perso i propri cari per questo
virus e cerco di relativizzare il tutto
non molto bene mari sono una ragazza
pugliese domani ci sarà il delirio
perché molte persone da milano stanno
arrivando qui e qui purtroppo la sanità
non è granché rispetto a quella del nord
se stanno collassando agli ospedali al
nord figuriamoci qui non mi vedo con mio
ragazzo da domenica scorsa ci siamo
messi in quarantena non molti dei miei
amici sono usciti lo stesso i locali
agli uffici sono ancora tutti aperti e
mia madre va lo stesso lavoro perché non
chiudono
ufficio e resta molto contatto con la
gente sono preoccupata
idem per i mesi che sono di cremona e da
quello che ci stanno dicendo la
situazione è molto grave
io vivo in toscana e nel mio paesino
mille abitanti i contagiati sono due
di solito su una persona molto ansiosa
paranoica cerco di non uscire se non è
estremamente importante e seguire le
norme d'igiene che alla fine sono
soltanto comportamenti di buona
educazione
non c'è bisogno di impanicarsi fare
gesti responsabili
usiamo il cervello e non mettiamo in
difficoltà i medici alla fine è vero che
per una persona giovane in salute una
semplice in fuga influenza ma questo non
ci autorizza a fare come vogliamo perché
poi magari lo attacchiamo persone più
deboli anziani che magari non ce la
fanno
questi sono solo alcuni dei messaggi che
ho ricevuto appunto da ieri sera
ovviamente non riesco a leggerli tutti
ma il succo è che siamo tutti molto
spaventati preoccupati ma sono molto
contenta perché tante persone appunto
stanno ragionando e cercano di limitare
al massimo appunto le uscite appunto
evitano di scappare e di andare a
raggiungere propri familiari per ovvie
ragioni ci tengo veramente a ringraziare
tutti i medici e tutti tutto il
personale sanitario che sta lavorando
notte e giorno interrottamente per
cercare di debellare questo virus e per
guarire i malati
siete veramente il nostro orgoglio e
grazie di tutto quello che state facendo
io sono super convinta che ce la faremo
anche questa volta siamo un paese
meraviglioso e un popolo con un cuore
enorme
e in queste occasioni sono queste le
occasioni in cui dobbiamo tirarlo fuori
rimanere uniti e farci forza tra di noi
cercare di seguire appunto le semplici
regole che ormai ci stanno raccomandando
da jordi seguire quindi lavarsi bene le
mani non toccarci bocca naso e occhi
evitare di uscire evitate di uscire il
più possibile se non per ragioni di vita
o di morte insomma
lo so non è facile stare a casa però
durante tutto l'anno diciamo e non vedo
non riuscire a dormire tutto il giorno e
dolori riuscito a finire la mia serie
preferita bene questa è l'occasione per
fare quello che diceva che vogliamo fare
tutto l'anno e che ogni volta non
riusciamo a fare abbiamo del tempo da
trascorrere con noi stessi possiamo
leggere possiamo appunto guardare serie
tv sono una pazza di serie tv adesso le
finirò tutti in questi giorni e niente
ragazzi ci sono tanti modi per passare
il tempo non è questo il problema può
essere noioso per carità non è
divertente stare tutti questi giorni a
casa
sicuramente ci ci mancheranno le amiche
e gli amici le nostre persone care ma ce
la dobbiamo fare perché questo è l'unico
modo per cercare di diminuire i contagi
e quindi per far sì che tutti tutti
quanti i malati riescano a guarire e
sono convinta che ce la faremo
non lo so quali video riuscirò girato in
questi giorni perché ovviamente è un
lato il morale un po terra dall'altro mi
piacerebbe tanto insomma trasmettere che
come sempre la mia allegria e farvi
divertire farvi sorridere soprattutto in
questo momento magari stupirò vediamo
cosa vi viene in mente in questi giorni
e sicuramente per restare in contatto
con me
se non avete ancora fatto seguitemi su
instagram perché lì ogni giorno insomma
pubblico delle stories e su tik tok
ultimamente sto facendo tanti tik tok e
quindi seguitemi anche lì vi mando un
bacione grande
fatemi sapere qui sotto con dei commenti
come state affrontando la situazione
cerchiamo di darci forza vicenda non ci
buttiamo giù e abbraccio forte
[Musica]